hello and welcome to inside Germany
my guest today will be familiar to many
DW viewers of our arabic service he's
been working for the company since 2008
for the first few years dividing his
time between Berlin and Cairo reporting
naturally on the changes taking place in
the Middle East
jaffa abdul kareem now presents a
program called Shabab talk here on DW
which is a talk show for young people a
show which amazingly has over 4 million
viewers in egypt alone every week
welcome to the program I own my first
question at Shiite it's the only
introduction I've done where I haven't
mentioned the nationality of my guess
and that has done quite deliberately
because you kind of have two
nationalities don't you yeah I have more
than one nationality as you already said
and I think asking about nationality I'm
not the kind of person who should tell
me what nationality do you have I'll
give you a straight answer because I was
born in Liberia in Monrovia and where I
spent my childhood then I went to school
in Switzerland then continuing school
and high school in Beirut at four at the
German School in Beirut then coming to
Germany studying here being also having
to to exchange students being in Lyon in
France and in London so when asking what
nationality I always say are my parents
are from Lebanon so they want me to say
rmally be nice but I feel also like I'm
a citizen of this world because I've
been different raised up in different
cultures and I don't think when I talk
to you and I talk to different people I
never asked for the nationality I just
talk to the person and through talking
to the person and having a discussion I
discover who this person is and it's not
about nationalities nationalities are
just done to have the logistic things
from my point of view like you have the
passport I have the liberties passport
and a half the German passport and
that's only done for a document to
travel but is that why you've got a
German passport or was that was the more
to it than just the document to travel
do you feel yeah it is a donkey
I feel home in this country I feel well
this country I feel home in Berlin
that's the place where I feel like okay
I wake up in the morning and say wow
it's nice to be here I feel it's a place
where I can identify myself it's a place
where I feel well I feel you it's just
me being able to live here in a place
where I feel yeah you could do
everything you want and you have work
you have a private life that you also
enjoy you have work that you also enjoy
you have friends you speak the language
you know a lot of people and yet Berlin
it's the atmosphere of Berlin it's the
feeling well in Berlin I mean I think
this thing about nationalism I I hope I
mean what you've just said you're a
perfect example of your generation yeah
who are getting rid hopefully of
nationalism and as you say use you meet
someone and maybe my generation would
have said where are you from and that
question if I say if I I said that to
you yeah your explanation wasn't saying
well I'm from Lebanon or I'm from yeah
it's great yeah nicely I mean because
it's it's a lot of predisposition if I
ask you where you're from and you tell
me I'm from Dublin then maybe I know a
lot of things about Dublin and then I
think ah that's you but maybe it's not
you at all you have your individual
personality your you made out yourself
what you are now so it's not the culture
where you come from it's like what you
make out of it you know and being being
also able to speak different languages
and know different cultures and
understand different cultures and being
able to exchange and be ready to have
dialogue with other people that's
amazing why should I like put someone in
one nationality or one corner
why don't I discover this person and we
all together can have like more common
things than rather being different but
as you said you were born in Monrovia in
Liberia and you spent the first 10 years
of your life there in an English school
yes so you obviously spoke Arabic yes my
parents speak Arabic so your English is
your sort of second language that's also
question what's my second language I
mean I I think I don't have a mother
tongue it's more I feel when in what I'm
talking now and I also
I always say I never talk one language
like perfect you know it's like when you
live in different countries you know
different languages and you you just
used them and when I was in in Africa
my parents are Lebanese so they talked
to me Arabic they still now to talk to
me Arabic for sure but for them it was
important that I get also a good
education knowing the English language
so they sent me to international school
and that's why I was able to learn
English and talking to different people
there who were part of the community you
also taught you also talk English and
maybe if you know a lot of people coming
from from Lebanon because they travel a
lot they know usually more than at the
more than one language should be used
and you might ask like German the first
thing when I learned German is what
Schwitzer ditch now yeah I was coming to
this we have to explain yeah to the
audience that yes your first knowledge
of German was a language that the
Germans sort of on earth there yeah
because it's what would swiss german
spitz a Doge and I want that you can you
can you actually say something in
Schwitzer doy I try Mina have been a
time like maybe then more than 13 14
years but it's like um it has numerous
agua
that's fits a ditch and in German it
would be say like it can is Nick Mercer
good and that's the difference I don't
know if you know now that yeah I do it
again that for kasnia so what it's which
is like I don't know I don't know it
anymore that well or in Germany would
say can easly schmear sakuya and
introverted it it has numerous awkward
and actually for me it was like for
granted to talk Schwitzer ditch because
I learned German in in Switzerland but
at school you learn like the real German
language but in you talk in this society
and with friends you talk the Schwitzer
do it's a real real strong action yes
it's an accent that that you can use we
talk more a bit about when you came to
Germany and that's but what I want to
know to now is is how did you come to
Deutsche Welle
or DW as we that yeah okay cuz there is
stuff in between and we'll come back to
the Deutsche Welle
I I finished my education then I had
media training here in Germany and
different and media companies and I was
a point-like saying what do you want to
do out of your life where do you want to
work
do you want to work like in a cotton in
a media company that's national do you
want to work in a media company that's
international and then I was in Berlin
and I was said okay I got it
international broadcaster it's Deutsche
Welle so I applied for Deutsche Welle
I have the background that I have and
the languages that I know and the way I
am is I think fits into Deutsche Welle
and was that about the time there was a
sort of increase of the Arabic service
as well I'm trying to think of dates it
was 2008 yeah like Arabic service what
was I think I don't know anymore how
many hours but we were really doing well
yeah and then I came in and I was like
at the right time at the right place
because there was a youth talk show
being done and they just started it and
they said okay this guy's the right
person for this show and now I'm sitting
here after six years with you being one
of the DWS presenters okay we'll talk
more about how you found Germany when
you first came to study a little later
right now I think it's time to see what
Jaffa does here at DW okay what every
week about Jafar in his element hosting
DWS popular show for young people
Shabaab talk
Allen become fish about talk
Albarn emoji loose track by nikana dwl
mania wall hyatt al-masri the talk show
is his greatest passion he loves to get
people from Germany and the Arab world
involved in lively discussions of the
burning issues of the day he's maybe a
local Ania
I don't know personnel alum on Fisher
who were topics touch on matters which
genuinely affect people's lives it's
often intense emotional and heated
almani
Jafar says it's essential to get out of
the studio - he wants to find out what's
going on firsthand he experienced the
Arab Spring at close quarters in Egypt
Tunisia and Libya
his documentary about events in Egypt
won international acclaim he's
constantly on the go the demands of the
global news cycle leave little time for
sleep daddy Kawada we are awake 5 o
clock in the morning yes and now it's
11:30 evening it is that's the real life
of a VJ but no Bogota oh yeah I think
it's time to go to sleep Nona yes you're
right good night good night when Jaafar
isn't working on a news story he's on
Twitter and Facebook keeping fans
up-to-the-minute his tech passion and
social networking skills made him a
natural choice as DWS first social media
correspondent he's always on top of
major international stories especially
developments in the Arab countries all
right I'm joined now by Jafar Abdul
Karim he just returned from Libya in
Jafar you produced the story that we
just saw on the situation in Benghazi
the multi linguist also pops up on DWS
German and Arabic news services
tasaku
Teta now and walk out fall yo hottie una
bohemian - dildos Uli ll madrasah as if
this weren't enough he also presents the
Arabic version of our program world
stories from time to time as well as
numerous live events in Germany and
abroad media forums discussion panels
awards ceremonies it's important to
exchange ideas with other journalists
and activists he's currently at home in
the heart of Europe that German capital
Berlin just the place for a cosmopolitan
soul with a dash of wanderlust and he's
here in the studio with me it's a map
tour I mentioned four million viewers in
Egypt alone what why do you think it's
so successful they obviously needed it
yeah Shabaab talk is a talk show where
young people people from Germany and
Arab countries meet every week to talk
about socio-political topics and and I
think when we started we it was very
important for us to have a talk where we
can talk about everything that young
people want to talk about you had what
what like a big story transformation
phase going on now in the Arab countries
in Egypt like what you all do young
people play and what do they have to
change in order to be part of the
political system not just watching and
being on Facebook but really be active
part of what's going on in the changes
you have like some controversial topics
like homosexuality in the Arab countries
like you have even countries topics like
woman rights concerning women rights you
have every topic that every single young
person in Arab countries is interested
in and sometimes they can talk about it
but sometimes it's not easy to talk
about in some media landscape in the
Arab countries that's ciabatta talk mmm
we it's important to have like topics
concerning human rights and concerning
the rights of individual being the way
he or she wants to be these are topics
that we really talk about and you're
using those screens that's Twitter and
Facebook yeah because I mean we have
like three or four guests in
talk show but you have 200 million young
people in the Arab countries so we said
it's very important to be interactive to
to get also voices from people who
cannot be in this video so we put
questions on Facebook or Twitter and
people can give their opinion to the
topic and it's part of the talk show and
I think that's that's that's important
now you can do a talk or you can't do a
program without having the opinions of
the viewers but the viewers see it now
as a dialogue it's a way of interaction
it's a way of exchange and everyone is
using Twitter Facebook and the whole
social media thing so why not having a
part of it beside that we had a very
good cooperation partner in Egypt and
that's why we we got so much there's no
crunching at it being broadcast there
then there's no problem with it being
broadcast it's quite controversial issue
is quite controversial that's why now if
today we are not having any cooperation
partner in Egypt we're doing it on our
own because it's very important for us
to talk free without any censorship to
talk about every topic to have everyone
being able to be at the show and
sometimes it might be like a challenge
for some media companies in the Arab
countries to allow this but for us
that's like that's the DNA of Shabaab
talk like talk free let everyone talk
about everything and let everyone
discuss every point of view that is
welcomed according to do we see
concerning human rights and and yeah
this is a good time to bring in a friend
of yours the peach yeah yeah there yeah
it's a Moo awesome Yousef bassem youssef
just for people who don't know who he is
perhaps watching this program because
we're all round the world best music
I've done with him three interviews so
far and Bassam is for me he's the voice
of freedom of expression and freedom of
press in the Arab countries today why
because he is the host of a political
satire show in Egypt where he talks
about different topics no one might be
talking about them controversial topics
but he's very smart the way he presents
these topics it is alike in a way of
entertainment in a funny way in a comedy
way in a very sarcastic way so we had
two topics a bit like John stew
exactly the daily show yeah they tell
they say that bassem youssef is the Jon
Stewart of the Arabic countries and in
the way here is Louie a bit different
yeah look at very seriously the first
photo but now as you do keep talking
sorry this way it's the famous selfie I
did with him after the interview because
we are happy to have best and now being
broadcasted as a second broadcaster at
Deutsche Welle in the Arabic department
in the Arabic service of Deutsche Welle
and yeah the way he talks about things
III see him like he's the cool guy where
everyone else is being uncool tonight
these days and he's an important media
personality in the Arabic media
landscape too to be able to talk about
very hard topics in a very funny way and
people really like to watch him because
when you look at our country today a lot
of things going on so you need to have a
smile like ok hard topics yes but one I
had why not having a smile and he's able
to to give this smile to a lot of
audience and a big coup to get him on DW
yes yes it's it's a great step for us to
have him and but I think that's that's
that's Bassem being in a channel like
Nike or chabela because we stand for
human rights and freedom of expression
so it's great to have him as a colleague
and to win him as a colleague in our
Channel
yeah um I just want to ask you a bit
about the Arab Spring yeah I mean I know
you're a journalist and you you're
neutral
yes you have experienced there I mean
2011 were three years old um is it
progressing is it standing still or is
it actually stagnating much faster I
mean let's say what the change change
was this young people and people are now
able to say their opinion that's already
a big change for me from for instance
bassem youssef is on yes isn't olive is
not even even a joke yet but maybe maybe
let's let's be on the ground let's not
talk about personalities let's talk
about the young people who are looking
for a job
by looking for change and looking for
therefore the future because media
personalities always have a different
case but I'll think about an 18 year a
year old guy in Cairo or in Libya that
dreams of having a nice future and being
able to work and being able to to build
as a future that he dreams of and I
think that's what what changes now the
people and the young people say no not
with us before you could do everything
but now we have our voice we want to
change we believe in the change but they
also know now after three years that
this change is not happening within
three years as we can see it takes a
longer time but they are part of the
change they are part of giving their
opinion and I think that's the big
change that I see for sure a lot of
problems a lot of political problems
going on but that's that's a big turning
point of people being part of what's
going on in their countries not being a
passive part being an active part we see
it in Egypt I mean the first prayer
first president elected after revolution
they said no it's enough so he's now not
anymore president and I think when the
second president again comes and he is
not doing what the young people or the
majority wants looking for for democracy
and being all being the same having same
opportunities then it's going to happen
again they will not let anything go to
them okay I want to ask you about coming
to Germany
um how were you perceived when UK it was
Heidelberg wasn't it where yesterday I
mean I'm talking if you like
Islamophobia gain how are you perceived
when you came um luckily enough speaking
very good German it could have been with
this Sweetzer Doge accent
it spent very good German I'm interested
to know did you have a hard time no
because this is like a topic where
everyone you know you're from the Arab
country so you have been living there
and then you arrive here in Europe and
that's the first thing we say
Islamophobia and the whole thing I think
it's the way you deal with it I don't
see myself as being someone representing
a community or a country I see myself of
being an individual so if someone comes
to me and
talks to me about something concerning
of Islamophobia and the way Islam
countries are for me if they are really
attacking or doing it in a very negative
way I tell them you I mean maybe they
are not well informed so I try to inform
them and if they if there is no way of
action and reaction and a dialogue I
just stopped doing it because I'm not
here to change the opinions of others
you know the people who are really
interested in knowing other countries
and other cultures and other people they
will do it you have Google you can
search about everything maybe they are
negative and positive things but you can
also try to have a dialogue with
different people and ask and and know
the knowing the truth and maybe the
media because I go back and say you
cannot change the whole opinion but you
can't give it a platform for people to
talk together and when I go back to
Shabaab talk it's like it really a
circle all about doing that you know
when you have in Shabaab talk people
from different cultures different
religion talking to each other and
having a dialogue now today and then ten
years later they will be like talking to
other communities and so that's the way
you build out a good dialogue so I'm not
I'm not like the person who says Islam
before be Adam when people talk to me
it's everyone has an opinion they can
say whatever they want I never cared for
that and I never had even bad a bad
experience but that's because the way I
think and the way I approach people and
being in a country here I know my rights
and I know what I have to do I know the
law I know the language I'm part of the
society I'm an active part of this
society so it's not about waiting for
someone to tell me something or
approaching someone it's just I'm living
I'm an active part and it's my right so
let's enjoy Germany and Germany is a
place where you can really enjoy and you
can really reach when you want to do I
mean I came here studied and now I'm
singing as a presenter for international
broadcaster Germany's like Germany's
face to the outside world and I'm not
origin German I have the German
citizenship so you can see there is a
possibility it's the way you deal with
it and how positive how you understand
others how open you are how tolerant you
are I mean if someone doesn't understand
you so it's part of the whole game you
now not everyone kind of understand
anything and your house we said you're a
well-traveled man as well and and you
mentioned a bit earlier mention that
famous word that has got into the Oxford
Dictionary selfie and jaffers actually
made a selfie for us because he's he's
an addict we'll talk about that in a
minute
a moving selfie if you like here he is
on his travels and a little game for you
guess where he is before he tells you
well as you can see I'm now at the
plastic Catalunya
in Barcelona
sun is shining
so we are now at the freer as we're in
Cairo
as you can see now we are in London baby
you're in London baby
so where am I now it's in Dubai
you went on where and I know um and
Italy in Rome and behind me feel good
my ass where am I now it's in dirt land
it's the place where I live I feel well
here been living since wild and Berlin
is cool the Lina's hip and yeah it's
very like putting your head in your hand
there's a good okay that's right a lot
of people would envy you but I did
notice though when you're in Barcelona
you said something like and here we are
in but does that sometimes happen yes it
has you travel an enormous amount you
don't you when you travel a lot and I
mean globalization it's another new
thing so a lot of places where you go
are almost maybe the same and then
sometimes you really like I had it I had
it last week I was in Perugia being part
of the International Journalism Festival
and I felt like it's so multi-cultured
so international where are we now
you know comes back to what you said at
the beginning there but now you don't
nationalism this word has to go to our
language yeah check it out check it out
um I also saw that it said unspoken
human rights festival your documentary
the innominate was at about it was about
the transformation phase in Egypt called
after the storm and we traveled with a
colleague of mine we traveled like
through Egypt knowing what what what
transformation phases are going on
concerning the economy and concerning
also the the human rights and so it was
like a very compact piece I think it was
42 minutes about really getting deep and
inside two peoples are knowing their
stories and their everyday struggle and
challenges and yeah that's okay that's
the serious side of you believe this is
your next movie yes
not really we found Nixon yeah this
picture
oh yes yes nobody expected now I might
rethink about not putting everything on
Facebook and Twitter because that's
that's from Facebook I think right you
got it from Facebook yeah yeah it was a
penc fiction I did a director course at
the London Film Academy so we had the
chance to experience a bit about big
movies so I decided to
like part section to have the pang
fiction thing and it was really funny I
mean it actually does bring me to this
whole thing about modern technology you
film that on your iPhone not paying
fiction sorry the report yes there is
that the future for journalists you
think filming everything on iPhones all
at slightly more sophisticated but it's
getting more sophisticated by them it's
part of the future it's not the future I
would say it's part of the future I
think mobile reporting has been done now
a lot through different journalists and
I think you cannot ignore the role of
the whole small iPhone and the other
smart phones and the social media and
the impact they have on our daily daily
way we perceive journalism and when I
have this small iPhone I mean I can like
really travel the word and and make a
video and a picture with it and
sometimes it helps you in countries
where you don't get a permission maybe
you can use it yeah so it's it's an
Facebook and Twitter is that again yes
what journalists are going to be using
more yes I think yes because I call it
it's now interactive journalism it's not
anymore about one sided like I'm as a
journalist right a topic and then I send
it under people read it and that's it no
it's in two-way communication it's a
dialogue like the the my listener my
viewer wants to be part of it he wants
to participate she wants to be a telling
her opinion and that's why we should be
as generous should be much be more much
more open about concerning these things
and let's take it as an opportunity
you know our viewers and to use this why
not yeah I mean I agree with you yeah
can it sometimes be too immediate it
depends for what do you use it like you
can't use it as a the first source for
now you have to have verification tools
you can use and then you know if it's
the right thing or not so you have to
take care of it but if you know the
people and if you know the activists and
if you know the people you are talking
to and who are delivering some
information then you can trust them but
be very
and calm with it and be very like don't
use until you know where the
verification I mean the the Arab Spring
was also known as the Facebook
revolution wasn't it because perhaps it
wouldn't have happened without social
media it's it's not the Facebook
revolution it's part of it because you
have a lot of young people used a
Facebook and Twitter and the whole thing
but I think it's it's a tool they used
to just interact and to to meet and to
exchange ideas and to say okay let's
meet at six o'clock at Tahrir and then
we're going to have a big demonstration
and it was very important to also have
an awareness to the international media
you know they were able to contact two
international journalists and talk to
them because otherwise how would you
know every individual so it was a
communication tool that it was used it
was also has an impact on gathering and
and allowing people to say their voice
and the more people interact and it's
getting more serious and at the end that
what's happened what happens in in the
25th in in Cairo like it was a event on
Facebook that people said but a tool but
the causes are others economy but now
you're of course presenting a social
media program yeah on DW on the arab
program yes soon and as soon as they
hear your wonderful English yes you'll
be taking my job away because I believed
I was going to present there's nothing
but you are are you tell us about that
well it's it's a segment in the journal
and then using we have and we try to
yeah I mean a lot of viewers and listen
and our listeners and the people who
visit our websites want to be part of
what we're doing so why not giving Adam
the voice and letting them participate
and know what they think about different
topics and that's what we actually do we
say like tell us your opinion be part of
our talk be about a part of our journal
and we want to know what you think so
it's part of it journalism today is
interactive it's cross media in media
ality even different medium channels you
cannot anymore say it's like TV it's
radio it's online no multimedia
yeah um you're very busy you we can tell
from just this talk you're doing this
you're doing that no what do you do to
relax to relax
I mean work for me is not that stress I
when you do something that you love
that's your passion that you really can
identify yourself with it then you enjoy
it
but nevertheless I swim that's what I do
okay can we show this one it's been
you're already showing it I think right
yeah this is Jeff our swimming or it's a
very clever Photoshop no no it's really
it's not a Photoshop it's swimming it's
going to musicals it's meeting friends
but I enjoyed the whole traveling things
and the whole work thing is not that
stressful that I say like oh my god I
have to really have a distance I'm
enjoying what I'm doing and I I really
like what I'm doing and even when I have
free or I'm on vacation you can see me
like twittering and looking at Facebook
and seeing what's happening on the
ground because I'm interested it's like
oh yes apparently yeah sure generate its
gonna go on
have you ever seen that one No the last
piece that's about well you know you
know but for our audience is about a
German a classic sort of German rock
star and I was once in a hotel having
breakfast having to be honest had quite
a hard night before and we've got the
biggest shock of my life which is
sitting around me worth fifty of him
okay cuz there were 5000 Lindenberg
look-alikes okay anyway have you ever
had a photo a selfie taken with a
musical style no but I know that you are
a Musical star you do musicals I did a
musical or I've done a few but I did I
was you got musical stars wrong it has
to be said I was in the chorus of the
event very original Evita so shall we
have a quick sell yeah yeah yeah it's
not a chance to have to have me do this
it's their chance for me to have I'll
come over to you okay just let me quick
selfie whilst or there live on inside
Germany yes like the typical selfie
looking nights like so I've got it so do
you have relations to go on stage ah no
I'm already on stage now TV presenter
but I enjoy watching musicals and have
been seen like different ones in New
York and London Berlin and different
color different cities because what I
like about em musicals is the show it's
like it's the emotion you have there
it's not because as a journalist Lou you
have to be neutral you have to adapt to
certain and to certain topics etc etc
but being a mere watching music is like
who as he takes your way sing dance
colors show pom pom whatever the the
piece we show at the beginning with the
finished at Palace it's like a very big
show and I enjoy it like being being
just free when watching them yeah but me
dancing I like to dance but it's not
only
on the musical I don't know I don't
think it's a good idea then I thought we
were gonna break a story there um our
questionnaire a couple of things you
said to me which really fascinated me
favorite German word neat desta tots yes
which is a classic one because it's
three words they join them together it
would be nevertheless in English
why do you particularly when you say
neat daesil tots the way it sounds it's
like neat desert hot sand the way you
can I cannot explain it it's like I love
this word and and the way you use it as
a meaning like sometimes in a sentence
you're going on a way you're saying I
like this and that' but or nevertheless
nice desert hots you put another opinion
to it and I enjoy it using it and I feel
like when maybe sometimes when I use it
I feel like aha I understood the German
language I know the way the German like
it is funky nice gesture towards me okay
yeah you put as a good German
characteristic friendship yes
interesting yes because if I have a lot
of German friends again I wouldn't say
like German Italian whatever le Bernie's
friends is just it's just the way
friendship here is with some friends I
know in Berlin and we have really a
long-term friendship you can really
count on a friend here in Germany you
can really rely on a friend here in
Germany and it's a very honest trust way
and if someone is your friend then in he
or she is really your friend it's not
just hey let's be friend and we are all
friends and let's have that and this and
that no they really mean it and I like
it's honest it's clear it's very and you
know where you are then it in this in
this friendship so I couldn't I connect
to Germany I felt this often on on on
this program okay
yes and irritating German characteristic
actually sort of goes with that appeared
strangely enough because you say cold
neutral but give them a chance yes
that's also to do with this friendship
it's it's hard to get in yes but when
you get in you're in then you got it
yeah that's exactly yes
yeah German culinary achievement bear
bread they all love German I just have a
German bread with olive oil is like I'm
happy and you remember what you said
about the best thing about living in
Germany I think I said then live and let
live yes you did yes it yes you did yes
it is a dislike this because being in
Berlin like you really can do whatever
you want to do you can be whoever you
want to be and just um there are some
laws you have to apply which is okay
there are some social norms but you just
be the way you want to be and everyone
lets you be yeah the one the one you
want to be and it's it's freedom I mean
this the Berlin is freedom Berlin is
like you have so different perspective
so different cultures so different
people and everyone is doing what he or
she wants to do and that's that's not
for granted I've been in different
cities and I know that's not for granted
to be who you want to be and to live it
also but Lebanon which is your other
home if you like that yell evident can
considerably more free than other oh yes
if I mean if you're in Beirut it's it's
an amazing so yeah I enjoy being in
Beirut and enjoy having the the spirit
of Beirut people meeting in Beirut you
have a very good culture scene you have
a good party scene you have people who
are really open and you have people
coming from different countries living
in Beirut and yeah it's it's full of
life even going through the whole
challenges and political challenges that
it has every day and every minute still
the people are full of life and full of
dynamics and they say leh let's go on we
have we want to live we want to enjoy
our living and they look forward and I
like when someone is really positive and
optimistic and that's what I see in
people living in in Beirut and you think
with all this traveling around has your
perspective changed over the years if
you can think back ten years ago yeah
when you were first coming to Europe
okay like how has it changed you I've I
think I've learned too
respect accept every kind of person and
to deal with this person and to have a
very tolerant way the way I see
different different topics and different
perspectives you are more listening you
are more trying to understand rather
than having a predisposition on someone
you know that you're more open about the
whole thing when you travel a lot and
you meet people you see we are we have a
lot of common things and everyone has
his or her own own story is struggling
in life and searching for something and
that's like very common things we all
have that's why when I meet people from
whatever which-which level they are if
they are DC or if they are working in a
service work or they are doing different
things I have we are all humans it
sounds like very cheesy and oh it's it's
it's for granted but that's really it I
mean it's very simple when you
understand and try to know people and
try to understand them why let's enjoy
it let's know each other
you're very positive very positive
person it's nice nice to talk to you
much why not yeah exactly
why don't you it's the only way to be
yeah what's the next step for you with
with DW or are you flying off for no I
I'll continue doing Shabbat talk and we
are now at DW having a new structure and
we are trying to have new programs so
I'm very happy to be part of the whole
DW family and be it to be an active part
of DW and looking forward for DW to be
better and great and doing great job new
challenge is coming up from DW exactly
jaha thanks very much for joining us
today
they've been fascinating if you want to
write to us insider DWD e that's it I
got to say goodbye I'm told they want so
much like they we're gonna talk for ages
thank you